hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel and I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about Delta
reversal this uh actually came from a
comment from Big lad what's your name
hey glad 3368.
um it's been born in uh March 3rd 1968
but you know a Delta reversal is
a nice trade setup when it happens the
problem is it doesn't happen as often as
I would like you know it's something I'd
like to see happen a bit more often
um because it it is a it is a great sign
for a potential reversal and you know me
I'm always looking for any sort of sign
of a reversal in the market but before I
jump in you know if you've been enjoying
these videos be sure to subscribe to the
channel click the notification Bell so
you don't miss any new upload and be
sure to leave some comments you know on
what you'd like to see in some upcoming
videos you know I'm always looking for
ideas and the best ideas are the ones
that come from you guys in terms of
making videos uh explaining things so
let's go ahead and jump into today's
topic now Delta reversal
is something that is based off of the
Delta it's not necessarily price related
but again when you're dealing with Delta
right Delta is the net difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
Sellers and on a bar by bar basis it's
that difference in the bar between
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
and you know every bar is going to have
except you know maybe when a number
comes out you see one bar that's got you
know volume on one side and all zeros on
the other but that's rare and again a
Delta reversal what is it it's a
reversal pattern so when you see it what
are you looking for are you looking for
a move that just happened and you're
looking to reverse it it's not that you
just would take it in any old sort of
manner now one of the easiest ways to
identify it is if you're using a tool
like I have my Delta candles I
programmed this or rather I didn't
program my brilliant programmer uh did
it years ago for ninjatrader 7 and now
in Trader has added it if you get their
paid version of ninja Trader they have
it in there you
you know their paid version costs like
fourteen hundred dollars or some
something like that but it's uh what do
they call it here Order flow cumulative
Delta and if you're using this you'd
have to change it from session to Bar
okay but it's the same thing as the
Delta candles I just prefer the Delta
candles because
um
it's the one that we created ourselves
for our own use and so what am I looking
for in a Delta reversal okay so again if
I'm looking for a Buy Signal in a Delta
reversal
I'm looking for a new low being made you
know whether it's the new low of the day
or a swing low for a Buy Signal or for a
cell signal I'm looking for you know a
swing High obviously the high of the day
for a sell signal to come in okay so for
example okay I'm just gonna again I'm
just sort of pulling this out here this
is today this is an eight range chart
something simple and I'm just going to
draw a line here
okay because you know this is kind of
you know trading sideways here okay then
we start coming down
here we sort of break below and then
here we break below again now
what is a Delta reversal is you're going
to look at the Delta the internal Max
and Min Delta and you're going to
compare it to the final Deltas that's
why I say it's easy if you're looking at
a Delta candle because it's a visual uh
thing that that's very easy to see and
what you're going to be looking for is
for again for a Buy Signal we'll start
with that
you're looking for you know a new swing
low or you know a swing low to be taken
out and potential reversal to happen
okay or a bond market bottoming out and
then start to Rally okay because there's
two potential ones down here
what you have is a nice strong negative
Delta minus 496.
okay and the Delta ended up at 108 and
on a candle with a Delta candle what it
looks like it's got that long Wick down
so it's telling you at one point this
was a big
negative Delta right there's a big red
candle down and it turned positive it
actually closed positive so it went from
minus almost 500 back to zero so there
was strong
aggressive selling early in the bar
turned Delta negative
for quite a strong number minus 500 and
you're comparing that how do you know
it's a strong number well you're going
to compare it to sort of the recent bars
that you're seeing on your chart you
don't have to sit there and say you know
draw a line in the sand say well it's
got to be 500 okay and you know minus
496 it's not five I would still take
minus 496 as strong because I'm
comparing it to sort of recent history
yeah you got one bar that's kind of
strong here one bar that's kind of
strong there okay fair enough it's in
the middle of that range but we're
coming down here we broke out of a swing
low poked down a little bit couple ticks
below the low
strong aggressive selling they're seeing
if they could push the market down and
it came back so it went from nine minus
496 negative Delta back to zero so it
gained all that back and turned positive
okay then the next Bar opens up it's a
range bar so one tick higher new bar
forms then it came right back down okay
and formed a new low by one two three
four ticks and your sword is seeing the
same thing a push down here right minus
548 in the Delta and this time it it
only got back to minus 45 does it have
to be positive like this ideally yes but
even if it's still a small negative
right with e-minis with liquid contracts
when I look at Delta in a bar
I sort of have a a band so to speak you
know of about minus or positive or minus
50 meaning if the Delta is within 50
positive or negative I treat it as sort
of neutral because you know on a market
like e-mini s PS you know there's decent
wine that goes through if there was one
more trade that managed to go through
especially if you're on a Time
constricted chart like a one minute
chart if there was just an extra
nanosecond it could have changed from
positive to negative or neutral in the
sense of going back to zero so I'd still
consider this one a Delta reversal even
though it's it's negative it's a small
negative ideally I'd like it to be
positive
so this first one here this is one that
I'd be looking to take it failed then
the next one came in and you got a nice
move up again after this bar closes
you're waiting for the next bar to start
trading Higher by at least one tick I
prefer two
all right I mean if you see all my other
indicators that we have programmed write
the trade entry signal is based off of
two ticks that's why
um even though it went up one tick here
I prefer two that's just me some people
I know like to use one but
even if you're getting in here around
four and a quarter four and a half at
worst
it's a move all the way up to 14 14 and
a quarter Fourteen and a half it's a 10
point move so okay if you took this one
yeah you get stopped out you have a loss
you look for the next trade to come in
then you take it and why isn't this one
here one well it's in the middle of a
range you're not reversing anything
right it got down to minus 439 okay it's
kind of decent ended up positive at plus
78 but it's still in the middle of an
area
you know where the Market's going
sideways what you want right it's not
reversing anything all right and what's
the point of trading in a Delta reversal
if it's not reversing anything people
say well you got a small pullback okay
but that's not really how in my opinion
it should be traded let's see if we
could find one on the bearish side okay
so that's the bullish side you know
screenshot this right here and then
um make your notes let's see if we can
find a bearish one here now
we're coming up here around a high not
really because these two bars got strong
positive Delta 900 900 you see them just
standing out here quite strong what I'd
be looking for you know somewhere near a
swing high high of the day let's see if
we could
find an example no no examples here
let's just go back really quick uh a
different day
again you know it's a nice signal
problem is
you know with a lot of nice signals it
doesn't happen as often as you would
like
you know I wish these things would come
in you know
on a regular basis um it would make my
life and everybody's trading life a heck
of a lot easier but uh you know you can
only trade what the market gives you let
me just expand this up a little bit here
go to eight days
and uh let's see if we can find one here
or yeah that's
going to be nice and again you know for
a sell signal right you want the market
to have moved up
right because if you're looking to get
short right you want to have a move that
you can uh
take advantage of and again if you're
sort of going sideway let me just go
back here to the beginning uh we'll take
a look at during the U.S sessions here
um
this one you know it's a swing high up
here you got a nice positive Delta of
580 but it's still kind of a nice
solid green positive Delta of 149 if it
was down to like just 49 or negative
this would be a good example but I just
want to point that out like here okay
very strong positive Delta relative to
recent history because you know people
say well 423 that's not strong you know
but if you look at it over the last
you know in this case this is a neat
range chart so you're going back from
you know how many bars but if you just
look over time from you know the last
20 minutes it's the strongest positive
Delta 423 and it went from 423 down to
minus 174 and close that minus 173 so
it's got that big upper Wick
and the red underneath right that's what
you like to see in this case it just
started to move then went sideways and
then sold off
um
you know this would be nice if it was a
little bigger Wick honestly you know
it's only positive Delta of 233 but uh
you know if it was like minus 433 if it
got up to positive 433 that would be
beautiful but uh wasn't the case there
um
really what you're looking for are those
big long wicks
above and with a small body or you know
body going in the opposite direction
um like this one here
the Delta again is not that strong it's
only 309 versus previous bars a thousand
bars over here 700 bars over here is
800.
okay
I guess if it wanted to I mean we came
down here swing low bounced up a bit
again
when I'm looking at a you know swing
High I gotta take into account sort of
the recent history if I got a lot of
bars I'd consider that a swing high but
don't get much of a move there
um
really
here again 344
you know he was 336 he was 543 here's
544. so it's not as strong as I would
like
but again if you took it you got a small
trade going on right there this one here
this sort of the Swing Low minus 392 in
the Min Delta close positive 56. problem
with this although you know I'd love to
say oh yeah this is a perfect example
you see how the market went up
um but
previous bar has got a stronger negative
Delta minus 478 previous bar here it's
also got a even stronger negative Delta
minus 848
um you know maybe I'll do a video on
this but if you wanted to sort of draw
some trend lines of Delta
uh where's my line
tool
uh I've got F2
draw it like this right or sort of just
sort of going up like that
from a from a swing low you again your
price is going down Delta's going up in
that sense
people say oh that's a Divergence yeah
whatever you can do that in uh I can
cover that probably in another video but
you know that's I always like watching
how these Delta candles form and you
know sort of what shapes up in there and
let's see if we can find another example
of a cell signal here
you know it's just something I wish that
would appear a bit more often than it uh
really does
you know this kind of be nice here you
got the red candle you got the nice
positive Delta of 804 but still
it's still positive 108 if it was
smaller you know maybe potentially you
know 50 or you know even 58 I'd still be
looking to take it
you know but it's just a little too
strong still 100.
you know like this again I I wish that
this Delta had gotten a little more
positive like minus 50 or even zero but
it's it's a nice strong negative Delta
it only got back about 600 contracts
I'd like to really give it back all of
it
um and then make the move
uh
and again you know depending sort of
depending on you know the charts that
you're looking at
um you know maybe it's
you know if you're looking at certain
markets
again there's there's certain types of
charts I like to look in certain markets
you know with e Minis that go with time
base and range based
um in bonds I go with range based but
let's just see here if there was
anything I I find it better during the
U.S hours rather than during the night
session
um you just don't get a lot enough
movement in my opinion for the night
session for a Delta reversal let's go
here and what day is this
holidays again really talk about
September 4th but uh say September 5th
today
again you're looking for if you're
looking on a Delta candles it makes it a
hell of a lot easier because you're
looking for those big wicks
right something like this yeah I mean I
kind of like this I just wish this was a
green up candle not a doji candle you
did get a little bit of a movement okay
then you can see Delta just
progressively getting weaker weaker
weaker
um
you know this is one that I like here
728 or sorry 726 Max Delta got all the
way back down to 19. started to move and
then it just sort of went sideways for
you know the next 10 minutes before
selling off I I wish you know this is
one that I like it just took the long
way to get there before it sold off
right but that's what you're looking for
the long Wick the small extremely small
body
on the delta
right you can see it's minus 19. it only
got down to minus 58. I'm gonna close
that mine so it's got the very small
body here right it's a nice swing High
and a nice move up
which is unfortunate went sideways for
about 10 minutes before making that move
back down right but that's what you like
to see this one here
if there's any more today
uh nuts you know again you know here
right you got that big wick but then
that previous bars much stronger 685 so
that doesn't that sort of invalidates
this candle
about it just really quick I'll just
take a look at uh
other Market I don't know take a look at
Gold's I was looking at Gold earlier I
love gold
um
you know kind of
kind of this I just wish that
this was positive right instead of the
negative but I do like that big long
Wick that
got it all back but then I just wish it
was a little more strength but the
problem is again what move are you
reversing here there is no move right
this would be a move that you're looking
to reverse but not this one
not up here when it's trading 58.
again and if you're looking at a you
know Delta candles it's a lot easier to
see than trying to you know sort of
parse the data in the Delta itself
let's take a look at the
curious here bonds again bonds I use a
four range chart
uh-huh
nothing there in the bonds today
much further back can I go in the bonds
again it's very visual
you know this candle would be nice here
the positive 608
closing at minus 99 however
we've already started our reverse you
know I I wish that this candle on this
Delta was coming in you know on the high
or
one or two bars it's already coming off
the third did it sell off yeah
technically but it's already late in the
day it's already after one o'clock when
that bar forms
um
let's take a look at some since we're
here
we have buns
ones is a nice contract trade uh let's
take a look at today
yeah nothing in the Buns today how do I
go yesterday was the U.S holiday so it's
kind of quiet if we go back day before
this was the 30th
something like this you know it's one
you know you you made a move back up
towards the high the gigantic Wick here
although again when times are coming in
it's coming right on the uh sort of the
European Cash open it's gonna go down a
little bit Yeah it kind of went sideways
not too much small move
further
and they when you see them all right
you'll know it because it just really
sticks out
this one's already coming in a down move
here
again it is it's called the Delta
reversal because you're looking for it
at an inflection point in the market a
reversal Point coming in
you know this would be nice if it was
just a little bit closer to the high
here
because even though this Delta is quite
strong 844 this one this
you know
in the last hour even though it doesn't
look like much as a range-based chart in
the last hour it's it's still quite
strong
except for one other bar that's got more
but within that hour that's their
strongest
and uh lastly let's just pull it up as a
minute based chart then
go back to today
you know sell off bounce back up got
that big positive Delta 343
closes at just 28 I mean the 343 is
quite strong on in the positive sense so
132 129 years 249 218 200.
nothing else above 300 here
again is that a move
it's up to you to decide it's not
necessarily in an area that you're going
sideways yet I mean
you sort of broke down here popped back
up then you get that reversal but again
it's
how you define your own reversals
but like this I wouldn't be interested
in taking even though it's a strong
Delta 247 for where we at we're at the
low of the day I'm not necessarily
looking to get short at the low of the
day
you know hairs it's just a small bar
it's only two price levels but it's got
a nice decent Delta 227 it's right up
there with this one and this one here
it's closing negative
but it's again it's a doji candle just
traded two price levels maybe you you're
fine to take those me personally at I'd
pass on that because I like to have at
least the bar itself moving in the
direction I'll be looking to trade
so anyway guys you know I'll end it
there I don't I could keep pulling up
charts I mean that's what I do uh a lot
of times is
um I like to see it in in different
markets but uh I just wish it was
something that appeared more often but
unfortunately it doesn't
um you know you can see right I looked
at different charts over different days
but it is a strong signal when you see
it right and it's one of those things
where imagine you know like if you have
the page version of ninja caters or
sorry ninjatrader it's available on
there
um
you know it's available on I believe
it's on go charting I believe they have
it there if you get their package
um obviously I have my Delta candles
honestly
um I don't sell the Delta candles
anymore actively I mean people do
message me asking you know to they could
buy it and then I do respond I think
there are some free versions out there
floating around uh you just gotta like
use Google to find them but again I
don't know how good they are and you
know how stable they are I know mine is
is good but mine's like I don't know
what the price I don't even remember
what it was but um it's just something
you know you could have on there as
opposed to having to parse the data
yourself again the Mind processes images
at a much faster rate than
trying to do the number calculations
yourself so I hope that uh
what's your name
big lad 3368 I hope that uh satisfies
your question on Delta reversals so I'll
see you guys on the next video
take care bye-bye